islam has its back up with regards to
the west to such a degree
muhammad was a warlord
and i i don't know what to do about that
fact
like one thing you can say about christ
which you know
breeds a particularly pathological form
of ideologically rigid islam that
basically enslaves their women rather
vague that
that islam is in essence a religion of
peace and
but when i look at the historical data
say stemming from
the medina the medina time and then
moving forward
and the fact that muhammad was
definitely someone who engaged
personally in warfare
to what extent do you believe that
discourse with moderate muslims can lead
to reform of the ideology
such that the gap between islamic and
western beliefs can be bridged
well i guess we're going to find out
about that because that's one of the
things i want to do over the next couple
of years
have you heard of uh jordan peterson ah
the name doesn't read about yeah he uh
he recently um
he got sick what yeah whoa whoa whoa
for what he uh got on an anti-anxiety
colonopin
anti-anxiety medication you know i think
he's getting a little better
but for people like him like jordan
peterson or others
i mean they're highly intelligent but
then sometimes people end up talking
about they get out of their lane
and they start talking about islam and
they haven't even read the quran yes or
a good translation of the quran or sat
with
if you want to know the truth you have
to go out
and search for the truth yourself don't
rely on cnn
don't rely on a political
office that runs the country if you want
to know the truth
go out and find out take the quran the
quran
is is the source of islamic knowledge is
source it's the the the
the source of all of our religion it's
the it's everything encompasses
everything if you want to learn
go out and read read the quran go to a
masjid
go to a mess don't be afraid they will
be the most loving
inviting people you could possibly
imagine when you tell them
yes you know i'm christian i'm jew
i'm atheist i'm hindu i'm buddhist
it doesn't matter when you go in there
and say you know what
i don't know much about the religion all
i know is what i see on cnn the news
and i would like to learn some
information about what it is
subhanallah they will be like
oh please yes come come please
here can i get you some coffee would you
like some water um
here let me get you some information i
have a shake here
i have an imam here we'd love to of
course what can we do for you please
you're always welcome anytime yeah
that's that's being academically sound
because i mentioned his name jordan
peterson and because there's many people
know him but there's many people like
that again they get out of their lane
they start talking about islam they got
an opinion they form the opinion
off some fake news right exactly some
the wrong information
yeah now you used to 22 years in the
military intelligent individual was
a christian minister about to be a
deacon and you went against all odds now
you have the dean's show
as one who submitted his will to the
creator of the heavens and earth that's
it and uh
go ahead finish off with yourself yeah
so it's uh i mean you have to go out you
have to go
don't be afraid because you know one
thing i can say
the biggest fear for me in becoming a
muslim
was my own fear my f a fear that didn't
exist
i was fearful of the unknown
i was fearful i was thinking religion
people
don't change religion nobody changes
your
you don't change your religion you are
born a religion you live a religion you
die by that that's a false pretext
yes yes it is you know and it's that's
kind of like the the mindset
and i see that even with my own family
it breaks my heart like especially
now the muslim they're still christian
it kills me because there's so much
rooted there
in traditionalism this is traditionally
the way it has been
this is traditionally the knowledge that
i know this is what i practice i've done
this for 50 years 60 years 70 years my
parents
you know for for them to to think after
having spent an entire lifetime
following a religion
and then to say you know what i think
i'm going to change my religion
it's not normal so for jordan peterson
and others you mentioned read the quran
get around go visit a masjid and go to
ajummah ask your
questions okay i said you know what i
have to do more
i got involved with the the diaconate i
got involved with the church i became a
eucharistic minister
i became a an acolyte you were a
minister
yes yes very much so very much so uh i
started teaching
religious education deacon is above the
minister yes yes you're on your way to
go
yes in the rings yeah so in fact deacon
is actually the first official level
of uh ordination in the catholic church
it's the first
process of ordination so you have deacon
and then you're ordained as a deacon
and then you are ordained as a priest i
see someone
so minister deacon priest yes so
all priests start as a deacon and then
when they finish
their finish the seminary then they're
completed with uh they're ordained as
the uh as a full-blown so now you're a
minister and what are you thinking
so i'm thinking i'm like you know here i
was i was serving doing god's work
but i had something inside i had
something that was really troubling
deep down inside i couldn't believe i
never believed that isa was god
okay let's stop there because they just
did a new
survey that you do have today this is
recent
52 of christians or more
don't believe that jesus was god did you
read that survey oh i haven't
seven evangelicals this is the reason i
just spoke about it
i also don't believe that he's god yeah
so that's
part of our nature to kind of reject
that god is a human being
it is as a christian minister you were
having trouble with that
exactly because what kind of feeling
what do you you know it was a it was a
deeply unsettling i was deeply
unsettling
deeply unsettling deeply unsettling
how could i as an ordained deacon
as becoming ordained as a minister of
god
how could i be teaching a theology that
i did not believe
that's hypocritical so you so you're
believing in the oneness of god
that monotheism absolutely but you're
having a problem now with the trinity
or it's you know it's a whole factors
saints using saints's intercessors
asking praying to a saint to pray to god
no
look at the teachings of jesus looking
the teachings of isaac
never ever did he say pray to him to go
to god
never did he tell anybody he never said
pray to me and all pray to god no he
said pray to the lord your god
pray to him alone pray to no other
you know if you look everything says
pray to god alone your lord your god is
one
it's there don't make idols and i think
myself
well i look in the holy land people go
and they see these these
these relics and they they kiss them
they venerate them they they pray to
them
you know and i'm thinking to myself
you're praying
you're making idols you're so what
happened to god
why are you not praying to god why are
you putting so much
emphasis on jesus when you should be
putting that same emphasis into god
because it yes jesus did miracles but he
did them
with god's permission he did them by
god's
grace you know he he wasn't
he didn't just do it by himself did that
come off as more
feeling more natural now would you say
this makes total sense
it did it did and um you know what but i
it was such a
is such an untroubling feeling and you
know
uh alhamdulillah i had this wonderful
friend of mine a sister from indonesia
um
my sister ayunda who actually just
recently uh got married and is expecting
this december handle
but yeah but uh so she and her family
i was talking one day and said you know
i'm supposed to be going in the
diaconate
and i forget how we we were talking
about something and i never spoke about
religion you know
she's muslim i'm christian you know so
we never really talked much about the
religion but you know what it was
bothering me so much
i don't know what it was but something
inside me felt compelled
to talk about it and i was like you know
what
something's really bothering me you know
it's like i'm supposed to be going into
the diagonal i'm supposed to be
preaching all of this
but i don't believe it and you're
telling this too and i'm telling this to
my
my muslim sister um you know
and she was like well you know
everything that you're describing is
exactly
what islam teaches